and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I'm Ryan Nicodemus
and together we are the minimalists and
we have a special guest today welcome to
episode 163 today we're going to talk
about the lessons that we've learned
from running businesses over the years
and because we're gonna talk about
business today I thought we would bring
in a special guest now now Jordan we
don't do interviews what we do is we
bring people in occasionally and have
them help us answer some questions right
I thought you'd be the perfect guy for
this because recently you left a
business that you started and we get a
lot of questions from folks about
starting a business and so in a weird
way
you didn't Reese well you restarted yeah
wasn't started in a way it was starting
from scratch but bringing forward the
knowledge you already had yeah yeah and
it was traumatizing and everything along
with it in fact it was right across the
street okay which is kind of funny yeah
so yeah we're in Los Angeles right now
and in your business you ran the most
popular thing was the podcast or the
charm which I think you did for 11 years
for 11 years now I do the Jordan
Harbinger show which is like the
follow-through I don't know what you'd
call it the reboot I've been off the
spin off yeah anything change and
anything changes over time so what I
noticed with the art of charm is it
became this interview format show and
you're a really great interviewer thank
you and and so we don't we're not good
at interviewing so what we do is we just
have folks show up and answer questions
in fact usually it's just it's like the
Ryan podcast and I'm a guest sometimes
and then it's the Josh podcast and he's
a guest sometimes it but but can you
talk a little bit about the the
restarting before we dive into those
questions you you had built up this sort
of Empire that was hard to let go of I I
assumed it was yeah so I built the art
of charm my old show and my old business
for 11 years and it started off just
like you would expect from the name or
it's about like going out at in
disclaimer I started it when I was like
26 so it was about going out and meeting
people especially the opposite sex and
it was great and then I turned 31 32 and
I was like this is getting pretty played
out and then
I ended up meeting my wife and getting
married and I was like this is just kind
of sad at this point so I started
interviewing athletes generals military
people entrepreneurs really getting into
the interview game and really enjoying
that and my business partners were not
crazy about that at all because they
were like let's talk about picking up
girls and I was like hey we're pushing
40 it's pathetic
so this is this is something new there's
some behind the scenes you were getting
constant sort of pushback yes from your
business partners and that that
thankfully didn't come out in the
podcast you were able to sort of leave
that behind the turmoil of the everyday
dealing with each other but it sounds
like there was a lot of tension going on
in the background I'm sure I'm sure it
made things difficult to operate the
business there was yeah I actually had
to move away from Los Angeles I moved up
north to San Francisco because I just
couldn't even this it's so funny how
clear this all was gonna play out in
hindsight right I couldn't even be in
the room because it would be like oh we
should do this continuity thing where
everybody pays a dollar and then they
forget about that it's on their credit
card and I'm like guys I don't want to
do business like this like this is
weirdly like not not just sort of
internet marketing smarm but just kind
of like the ideas that were being tossed
around which thankfully most of which we
never did we're kind of like it in my
opinion unethical I'm a lot like you
guys I'm like let's create something
great that people want to pay for and
not be like let's hope they forget that
we have their billing information like
that's just gross yeah you know have
them forget that we're like constantly
reaching into their wallet grabbing $1 a
month right and not adding any value
whatsoever
exactly and that stuff just made me feel
gross and and you guys and I are the
same way in which podcasts are free as
everyone listening knows so I'm not like
how do I screw over the list I'm trying
to give them everything I have artistic
or or intellectual value as free as I
can make it before I actually go
completely bankrupt and run my own ship
into the ground and then on the other
side of the coin it was like how can we
squeeze every last drop out of everyone
who's listening and so those as you can
imagine those values did not align at
all that that kind of thing I had to get
away from it
but the reason I didn't leave right then
because people are going why the hell
did you even stick around the getting
and this is not shameful to admit
because it's very just realistic the
getting
was so good right like the advertising
we were doing really cool stuff with
that people did like and we were all
getting paid a lot and I was like I
can't leave I'd have to start over like
I did when I was 26 what am I gonna do I
have I'm married now like how am I gonna
how could I possibly start over and then
that choice was made for me because I
started to negotiate an amicable split
from my old business partners because
they wanted me among other things to
co-sign a loan and I was the only one
that had property and I'm like I'm not
letting you guys spend my money for my
house car wife family future kids like
you've already shown that you can't run
a business
I'm not sigh I'm you guys have an Xbox
and a dog I'm not signing over my house
so that started a greater conflict I'm
gonna put up my Xbox as collateral dog
is collateral yeah well man this is
gonna be a great show because I mean a
lot of these questions revolve around
people whether they're starting business
or they're trying to do something for
their business or if they're trying to
leave their business I mean I think the
two main things that we're really going
to get out of today's podcast is one
helping people understand how they can
take that leap what does it take to get
to that point where you can look at this
thing you've built and you can you can
walk away from it and the other thing
too is what do we do when we do start
finding our business is out of alignment
with our with our values and or our
beliefs for that matter yeah I think
that it's funny the the starting over
there's a big fear thing there right so
so Jordan you were afraid of walking
away yeah I had this dream last year and
it's one of the most memorable dreams
ever I had I had a dream within the
dream it was very inception like and
impressive I just know right I can't
even be a minimalist in your dream I
woke up in in the dream and I was like
like none of this whole minimalism thing
happened Ryan and I didn't walk away
from the corporate world we were still
in the corporate world which is a
nightmare actually
it's a nightmare within a dream and we
didn't walk away but I woke up and I
told you the whole thing like Ryan like
we we started this website and there was
this podcast and we did a documentary
and
and we were on social media and I we
were helping people live a more
meaningful life with less and I'm the
real stressed out one of the Dewar's you
can tell I Ryan's the real just calm
laid-back anything can happen to him and
in the dream he goes oh don't worry
about it man we could just do it again
like it was like this most profound
thing but it applies exactly to your
situation nice you can walk away and do
something that is in that isn't a lot
alignment with your values now here's
the thing maybe at one point time what
you were doing did align with your
values but over time you realize that
your values your beliefs your interest
your desires change and so what we are
clinging to is a sort of past version of
ourselves quite often and if we can't if
we can't change within the context of
that with it within the business then
maybe it's time to move on that's
absolutely correct your business should
or your career whatever you don't have
to own your own business it should
evolve with you so if you hear about
people getting stuck in jobs and like oh
I've just outgrown this job but very few
people say I've outgrown this business
that I started myself because usually
our business is able to evolve with us
or hopefully our business is able to
evolve with us but if you have other
people in the mix you're gonna grow at
different rates and this happens in
relationships too I mean anybody who's
been in a relationship and had to break
off with somebody because their values
change and I know that you guys have
gone through this at least and
especially you cuz you were on my old
show before and we talked about this you
have to be able to evolve and if
somebody is kind of reeling you back in
because of their values whether it's a
business or a relationship you've got
tough choices that you have to make
because you can't really toe other
people along that easily you can't
really go hey I want to interview
amazing people that are gonna help
people with their career and in their
life and in these other ways you guys
all have to change if they're rowing in
a different direction you're gonna be
miserable and even if they're giving you
enough leeway like I was with my old
show to do whatever I wanted they're
still gonna try to reel you back in once
they see that hey we could make more
money if you just did something you
hated especially my situation was unique
but not unique we know my face and my
name
at the forefront of the company so if
there was an embarrassing branding
choice made I was the one who had to
deal with it it wasn't them they get to
cash the checks just like everyone else
but I was the one who had to walk around
being like the pickup artist guy at age
35 which is sad you were responsible for
the horses horse and I think that's
that's something to keep in mind we I
remember we had this gal in Dallas right
we did a tour last year and she came up
she said well I have to have she's like
I don't want to but I have to have ads
on my website I'm like well if you wanna
have ads on your website it's fine but
you had all these like Google pop-up ads
and stuff in it and she goes I really
don't want to but I know I have to I'm
well that that's your problem is
thinking you have to continue to do to
do something that you don't want to do
if you want to do something then fully
embrace it but but sometimes we we make
these little sacrifices I remember what
you told her run when when she was like
well I'm gonna sacrifice this one little
value but then of course that starts to
snowball and then ten years down the
line you've made all these decisions
that are no longer in alignment with the
person that you wanted to become I can
see how that slope is very slippery so
in that example it's well I I'm in this
job I don't like so I'm gonna start a
side hustle well in order for the side
hustle to be profitable I have to have
ads on my website for example right well
if I get rid of the ads then I have to
work more at this job I don't lie and
then so there's all these weird choices
that start compounding and then suddenly
you feel like you're in prison when
really you just made a choice to shut
that door shut that door shut that door
lock that windows lock that other window
and then you go look this wasn't me look
at my circumstances yeah you know I was
in the same boat I was like I can't
start over well I could have it just
would have been hard and I didn't want
to go oh my gosh look at all the work I
have to do I wanted to go look at what
everyone's doing to me poor me I'm stuck
in this situation it'll be fine let me
go get a burger or whatever and just put
it out in my mind and then when I
started really clashing with my partners
and we in the whole deal fell through
the amicable split fell through and I
just got locked out of everything which
is now a lawsuit and everything like
that because of course you can't just
lock me out of everything
but then I had to start over and I went
oh okay now that this choice has been
made for me I'm gonna feel sorry for
myself for like 15 minutes then I'm
gonna call all my friends and find out
what the hell I can do to get out of
this mess now I'm in a better place than
I ever would have been had I stayed at
the old company the Jordan Harbinger
show is more popular than the old show
but I never would have found that out
because I didn't have the guts to go
maybe I should crack open this door and
walk through it and see what happens but
I understand why people don't do it
because it's freaking scary yeah well
it's also easier to go with the flow -
yeah the problem with going with the
flow is well you eventually end up at
the Falls yes well we've got some
questions that they have up we hop into
these and we'll talk a bit more about
well the business lessons we've learned
about starting a business etcetera our
first question today is from Johnny in
San Francisco I just had a question as
to what you guys see as a minimalist
business I've been running a catering
slash farmers market for the past
farmers market booth for the past three
years and wondering what you guys think
about expansion and taking on that to
expand a business that you are very
passionate about
I am also passionate about other things
outside of life outside of the
restaurant life though this is a good
thing to be flexible and travel as well
without a commitment of a brick and
mortar but to make a living from this
have to work part-time and do the food
booth apartment as well it's not
something that can sustain us for a long
period of time without you know I think
that Johnny is doing something important
here and he's realizing something where
he's asking some good questions here and
I'll say bravo for starting your own
business and not trying to take the
giant leap of starting a well I need I
must do this brick and mortar thing
right away it's not to say that that's
the wrong thing to do Ryan and I
actually owned a coffee shop or were
part owners of a coffee shop down the
st. Petersburg Florida it's a long story
but and it is a minimalist business for
sure and the aesthetic is minimalist but
also the way that we run it is
minimalist so he Johnny's asking how do
I run a minimalist business it kind of
what you what you mean by that do you
mean like aesthetic minimalism or in his
case I think he's meaning like the the
financial side of things now for me he
talked about the being passionate about
this business and I think that debt can
totally kill your passion oh yeah and it
limits your freedom to because if you go
all right we took on this debt well
actually I'd love to do this other thing
or like maybe I'd like some free time or
maybe we want to have kids well it can't
do that we owe three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to the bank for this
restaurant or this storefront and you
become indebted to a particular
lifestyle or work now I have to work 80
hours a week right I have to do this as
opposed to where you're at right now
johnny is I get to do this I get to do
the caterer I get to do the farmers
market so if I'm defining a a minimalist
business for me three things stand out I
think debt can be maybe the fourth thing
here you strive to be debt-free I'm not
saying it's impossible to run a
minimalist business with with debt it
just makes it a bit more difficult Ryan
and I don't do debt at all and our
personal life or in our business life
but I could see there are some scenarios
where you might take on you know you're
buying a building or something yes I
will always stand by there is no such
thing as good debt I mean it's it's
funny because what we say this all the
time and people will like send this is
really long email like well you know
it's basically if you have a lot of
money like they'll get the example of
Mark Zuckerberg who bought a you know 50
million dollar house and put it on a
loan because you had a 3% interest rate
but he can collect you know 7%
year-over-year on average with the stock
market and it's like yes okay if you
have millions and millions of dollars
maybe in that scenario might be smarter
to take out a loan but for all intents
and purposes everyone listening to this
I mean yeah there is no such thing as
good debt and by the way functionally he
doesn't even have debt that's right has
the money somewhere else yes that's
right for a guy like that he could that
house could implode and the insurance
company could go look we are out of
business we can't pay you and he would
go oh all right and his life wouldn't
change at all he'd be annoyed but if
you're storefront
it gets evaporated and you didn't have
insurance on it and you still owed that
debt it would crush your life and your
well-being and you would never oh you
would take a long time to recover from
that long time so so three things that
define a minimalist business to me
one is your actions or the actions of
the business aligned with the values of
the business now if you are a
entrepreneur solopreneur it's probably
your values as well in fact your
business's values shouldn't be different
from your own values or at least
appreciably different so that that's the
first thing the second thing is I think
every good business solves problems and
and quite often people people go the
other way around kind of what you were
talking about earlier is like hey what
so we have a bunch of solutions let's
find the problems yeah and the one
solution was let's take a dollar from
people every month and just silliness
yeah and so we I think every good
business or every good creative even
helps people solve problems and the
third thing that defines a minimalist
business for me is it grows only when it
makes sense
I think we're often told that like
unlimited growth we need to grow grow
grow no matter what that that can be
irresponsible I mean that there are
types of bad growth you know a tumor is
a type of bad growth and we don't want
that in our business obviously yeah well
I mean when I think about you know being
a minimalist it's it's you know it's not
about just being a monk and shaving your
head and having nothing I mean it
certainly haven't you know no no and
that's because you know Josh Knight
we're not really concerned with the
amount of items that people own it's
more about our people living
deliberately because we live in such an
impulsive society especially with all
the advertisements we've seen the
pressures from society and success we've
got to be successful I mean we have all
these things that really make us not be
so deliberate so with Johnny here you
know yet man I would say if you can
avoid that
Johnny avoid the debt now there are some
debts that are better than others you
know payday loan is gonna be much much
worse than than than a you know a seven
year fixed mortgage I mean they're
they're definitely better better debt
there's better debt to get in than
others so I mean if Johnny has to get
into debt I don't know man what what
could well how could we help Johnny
reason to get in debt I mean is there a
reason I guess that maybe that's a
better quality Island Alice right like
if Johnny
have to get in debt then maybe he's
lying to himself yeah
or it has to materially affect in a
positive way and this is just my opinion
his quality of life so if he hates that
he has to work part time and the
bottleneck is his personal time and he
would love to run a brick-and-mortar
business and he thinks that's gonna be
great but he would need a loan to do it
that's something to consider but if he's
just going all my friends say that I
should grow this business and or I feel
humiliated having to work part time then
we're talking about ego issues
definitely not a good reason to borrow
$300,000 from Chase right it reminds me
of this this parable you guys are
probably said there's a thousand times
on the show so stop me if you have
there's this guy this the executive
flies down and there's a guy fishing and
he goes out and fishes and he goes hey
if you just worked a little harder you
instead of just fishing all day you
could buy another boat and then you
could buy another boat and then
everybody else could be fishing all day
and you could work a couple years of 80
hour weeks and then you'd own the
company and then you could just retire
and fish all day and the guys like yeah
that's what I'm doing right and I
started butcher this parable but the
idea is people work really really really
hard and they're ending up doing the
exact same thing in retirement as they
could do now yeah the difference of
course is if he hates what he's doing
now because there's elements that he
could get out of with a couple years of
hard work and a little bit of debt then
yes but if you're if you're just praying
that the stars align and you don't fail
which is what a lot of brick and mortar
food or restaurant businesses are you're
just rolling the dice and it's it can be
really dangerous because then you have
the debt but then you're working three
part-time jobs and you're doing the farm
cart and you don't get to keep the money
it's going back to chase according to
Forbes I was just reading this recently
in preparation for this there's when 90%
of businesses fail in the first five
years and we hear this similar stat all
the time and that that is I think both
bad news and good news yes the good news
is if you fail you can move on start
something else the the good news is that
a lot of other people are failing and
you can learn from their lessons as well
and so if you look at people who have I
taken whatever template you know the
farmers market thing or if you wanted to
start at a brick and mortar store you
can look at that temple and say what do
people done well what have people done
poorly I remember when I first left the
corporate
I was thirty years old and it was after
12 years in telecom and I managed 150
retail stores oh my gosh which which I
know is really ironic with the whole
minimalism well yeah I mean this is very
minimalist absolutely and what toward
the end of it I was when I first when I
first embraced minimalism Ryan and I
were both in the corporate world working
the same telecom company and I realized
like this in the line with the person I
want to be and I just wanted to go write
fiction I had written fiction throughout
my 20s that was the thing I wanted to do
and I had people at work like when I
when I finally decided to quit I put in
several months notice had a whole
transition plan and people came up to me
said but were you really going like they
thought I was going to a competitor or
something right because take me with you
yeah and I'm like I can't I'm just going
to go right and and I had more than one
person say you know if if anyone could
just quit their job and be a writer
everyone would do it
and I'm like you realize there are some
people who make a living from writing
write hi this is the first time this has
ever happened right and but what I
realized is that there is a template
people earn a living from doing what I
wanted to do and I could find several
different recipes tweeze out the
ingredients that work for me learn from
other people's failures and that's
because a lot of people do fail along
the way to success and so maybe we can
talk about some of the the failures that
that you've gone through Jordan and in
the past that have gotten you to the
successes that you have right now yeah I
think every time I think something is
successful then I look back at it later
I'm like well there's a little asterisk
next to it where it's like that didn't
quite work out the way I wanted to and
I'm not one of those everything happens
for a reason type of guys but I am one
of those you can take a lesson from
anything type of guys yeah so when I
looked at it makes it that's a good idea
by the way because it makes it really
hard to regret stuff it makes it really
hard to regret stuff if you focus on the
lesson that you get from things yeah
which I know is easier said than done
because this isn't a fortune cookie
where you can just be like oh there's a
lesson in everything good I don't feel
bad about any of my decisions now I mean
I wish that way the case but when I look
back at let's say starting a business
that was focused around dating and
relationships that was not the ideal
business for me to start because I
quickly lost interested in that and what
I was really interested in was human
behavior
but starting a vaguely human behavior
related business was not really
something that was gonna work for me but
I my biggest quote-unquote failure is
probably the idea that I went to college
tried to get a job at Best Buy couldn't
really get a computer repair job they
wanted me to sell CDs and I was like
standing next to a life-size cutout of
Britney Spears and just what happened to
my life after a four-year degree from
the University of Michigan and then I
went to law school because I thought
well the solution of this problem is
more education which speaking of debt is
basically the same thing going to law
school or grad school in general because
you feel like you don't have enough
education and not because you're
interested in the topic is the worst
idea but it makes sense if you look at
our parents generation because half of
them or more than a half probably any
would go to college so it was like hey
if you go to college you're gonna get a
great job well the if you extrapolate
from that if you go to grad school
you're gonna get a better job than
people who just went to college we're
gonna get better jobs to people who just
went to high school now though the part
they don't tell you grad school at a
really top school is probably like a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
three years so that speaking of limiting
your freedom I was like I don't even
want to be a lawyer but I'm gonna get
this great legal education and then
towards the end I got job offers from
Wall Street and I was like no way man
I'm gonna do my own thing
I might work for the government because
then I can go travel and do all this
cool stuff and it's like here's what
you're gonna get paid from the
government here's where you're gonna get
paid on Wall Street oh and by the way
your level of debt if you work for the
government you're gonna pay it off in 87
years and if you work for Wall Street
you can pay it off in like five years
and it was like oh cool well I'm only
gonna work on Wall Street as long as I
need to and then you start doing the
math and you're like four years when
you're 27 is a long time yeah and you
keep going and you keep going and I'm
not this is not news for you two guys
from coming from corporate you get these
golden handcuffs and I luckily avoided
this because the economy took a huge
dive yeah but guys that had started a
couple years before me they're working
on Wall Street and they're like oh yeah
well I'm gonna get a boat cuz that boats
are cool and I'm really bored of my job
and I can then go to this boat every
weekend and then they're like well I
should just get a house in the Hamptons
and park my boat there
and oh and then I'm gonna get married
and have kids and well my wife doesn't
want to take a lifestyle hit and she's
you know she's taking care of the kids
so you got these we call them golden
handcuffs because it looks like your
life is awesome but then if you wake up
one day and you go I am sick of this
corporate BS then you go what wait a
minute two mortgages a boat two kids
I've got to take care of my family and
that's if you were responsible right
imagine the guys who just bought a bunch
of shoes like those guys are totally
screwed they got no assets remember
every time someone in our that worked
with us when they would get a house or
they would get a car like our boss he
would be like yeah keep getting buried
in debt because he knew that he could
treat that person worse he could put
them through the wringer because they
were beholding to to that paycheck to
pay all the different payments you're
getting overtime you're getting the flag
for the flagship store that you managed
at one point in time in Centerville Ohio
I pulled up once I was at the time I was
a regional manager for like 16 stores
and I pulled up in my Lexus and yeah one
of two and and I pulled up and there
were two Hummers a Corvette and our
Mercedes and these were all front-line
retail employees what I know right now
we're Hummer is like 70 grand yeah
absolutely
earth is going on well right a massive
amounts of unsustainable debt is going
on they're like they're like I made a
few good Commission checks I can prove
that I can afford the debt payment on
this thing this is also at peak insanity
will peak insanity being like well we
can stretch this to a 63 month turn and
you can afford to pay these you pay for
this Hummer with your retail job as long
as no other emergency ever happens your
life over the next 63 months then you'll
own this Hummer and they do the Munson
because every number after 12:00 you're
like okay right like that's a year then
you're like ways holy crap but it'll be
a hundred months Yeah right
my kids are gonna be driving this thing
yeah
exactly and so the one other stat that's
worth talking about our friend TK
Coleman he's doing these these series
that sort of against the arguments
hefney calls it the bad college argument
tour he's going out to like colleges and
and like dealing with people's best
objections about why why should you get
into debt to go to college and there are
some you know good objections out there
one is like well the people who on
average people with a as you just said I
people with a degree earn more than
people without a degree which is true on
average but it also conflates causation
with correlation there yeah but the
other thing is I think the stat was 71%
of people with graduate degrees are
currently under employed yeah and so you
now you have $100,000 worth of debt and
you're doing a job that didn't require
the degree that got you into $100,000
worth of debt it's probably because
99.9% of graduate schools don't train
you for an actual trade right that stat
I obviously made up but think about this
if you have a PhD in statistics you
might go to work for a firm that does
you might become like an insurance
executive or something like that but
probably you're gonna start off doing
something that somebody who has a BA in
English is also doing and I might you
know whatever if I got that particular
subject area wrong fine replace it with
any other graduate school subject area
that's not engineering Computer
Engineering law medicine or something
that readily prepares you for an actual
job so if you're gonna be a doctor yeah
you gotta borrow some dough but you're
going to be a physician you're going to
get employment somewhere right but if
you're going and you're like I just
really love and trying not to say
English but that's the first one that
comes to mind that is quote unquote
useless you're going to end up with the
same job as somebody else who just has a
basic college degree in almost every
case unless you are really crafty and
the reason that we get there is we're
told that well well in order to be
successful you need to go to college and
get this underwater bubble gum chewing
degree and now here's no YouTube bubble
gum underwater now you can be a barista
right
yeah and that's where we end up and then
you start looking like we're Johnny is
right now and you say okay
in order for me to feel free I need to
start my own thing I need to have I want
to do my own thing because of the job
that I'm working it's no it's no longer
fulfilling it's not satisfying and I
guess the last bit of advice I would
have for Johnny is it part of it has to
do with a plan but you've already
figured out what direction you want to
go in now the question is how can you
get there and still make it something
that you love doing a few months ago
around we did a podcast episode with
Paul Johnson from a band called Canyon
City and one of our favorite musicians
and he actually opened up for us this
summer on tour and one of the things
that he did is he messed up when he
first moved to Nashville to do music he
signed this big recording contract I
started doing like all these jingles for
coca-cola and stuff and well I mean it
was like yeah he finally made it man
like he had you know someone offering
him money he's a paid musician so that
was his goal and that's the thing that
he loved into this thing that he hated
because he was now behold will do that
yeah good soon your hobby into it people
always like then I can be a professional
XYZ and I'm like oh that's a really good
way to kill your passion yes yeah a
really really good way to destroy the
thing that you don't think you doing in
the world
so maybe the sum it up is I think a
minimalist business never puts money
first but also we have to keep in mind
that money is going to be part of the
equation would be lying for ourselves if
you're running a business saying I don't
need to to make money yeah it doesn't
work that way it's just when it becomes
the primary driver for doing what we do
that's when it kills our creativity it
kills our passion and it kills our life
yeah I really like what you said the
advice you had for Johnny is like ask
himself why he wants to open this up why
does he want to take out this debt and
then Josh to your point about does this
align with the person that he wants to
become so Johnny ask yourself why it is
that you want to grow your business and
does it align with the person that you
want to become what I'll say though I
mean no matter what I mean whether
Johnny takes out debt or not I hope you
can avoid it but regardless as long as
he has as long as he has a plan and as
long as he is working in that plan and
it doesn't go against his his values I'm
he's
be on the right track yeah I think one
last tip if I may is do not quit that
part-time job that you have Johnny until
you're the bottleneck in whatever it is
and you can't outsource anything else
because there's this trend among
entrepreneurs now and they're youtubers
and instagramers that are like quit your
job go all-in and I'm like wait a minute
did you follow that advice first of all
probably not secondly why do that you're
burning the ships for absolutely no
reason you're adding a ton of stress
what so you can tell your mom like look
I'm a full-time entrepreneur I don't
even have a regular job now fine why
though right why you're just adding
stress keep that part-time job because
if things go downhill and you hit a slow
season or oh my gosh this supplier
screwed us over and now the money's gone
and we're waiting for them to refund it
but we didn't get the product you can
probably scale up those part-time hours
and survive and you don't have to worry
about it people go oh I'm quitting my
job what are you doing all day well I
have social media to take care of I got
this to take care of if you work at Taco
Bell and you're making fifteen bucks an
hour fine quit your job do it yourself
if you have a job that's paying you a
decent wage and it's not killing you
like literally keep it and then hire
someone else to do that social media
which by the way has like zero ROI for
your business absolutely and then have
them do it and then when you find that
you just can't outsource anything else
anymore because it's the amount of
finite energy that you have to do
whatever it is you specialize in you
know makes sense for you guys not to
have corporate jobs and to do your shows
and to create all the films and all the
the podcasts that you're creating only
you can do that but if you're sitting
there answering all your tweets and it's
taking you four hours a day hey Jordan
to do it yeah he'll do it
yeah and we outsource that years ago I
think you brought up a really good point
with the social media thing our friend
Matt the Avella who directed our
documentary minimalism that's on Netflix
he he did this 30-day fast recently I've
been telling him for over a year like
that exactly what you just said hey
there's very little ROI and there's
there's there's some value you can gain
from it
but if you're looking at it as the
primary driver for your creativity man
that is miss spent time and and I'll
tell you very recently since he walked
away from social media he
has been killing it adding immense value
cuz he's he's a genius filmmaker and so
he's doing these little five to ten
minute videos on YouTube and they're all
getting millions of views and and it's
from walking away from this thing and
adding immense value so ultimately
whatever Johnny's gonna do or whatever
it's someone listening this is gonna do
you have to remember that that adding
value to people you minimalist business
is as people focus whether it's your
customers or clients or readers or
viewers or listeners but also the people
you work with and and being people focus
creating outstanding experience for the
people you work with but create an
outstanding quality of whatever you're
producing for the people that you know
you're solving their problems you guys
find that social media has was bad for
you when you were doing it I mean social
media helps spread the message because I
mean you know it turns out Facebook is
where a lot of stuff is happening so
it's a great vehicle to use for certain
aspects of the minimalists to kind of
spread you know our story to spread our
message twitter is more we use it for
different reasons but i think that is
what we've done with social media is we
will take twitter will take facebook
we're on instagram and we will use each
vehicle deliberately it's not like we
it's not like we send out a tweet and
then it goes to our Facebook and then it
goes to our Instagram yeah each vehicle
is used for a different reason so I
think it does I mean personally I don't
have a personal Facebook account because
that does nothing for me sure but as far
as the minimalists go I feel like it
does add a lot of value to a lot of
people and it is weighted to kind of get
our word out there I think that at the
beginning of the year we took a step
back and we were doing just that we
realized like the definition of the
sanity is doing you know the same thing
over and over expecting the result we
were doing that we were like posting
everything in triplicate where it was
like well here's our Twitter post let's
repost that on facebook and re repost it
on Instagram I was dealing that too yeah
and and so at the beginning the year
Jessica who runs our social media and
she's she's really amazing really
talented artists in fact she used to
curate like museums and galleries and
and so she's a curator of things and she
does a really good job of this and so
the beginning a year we literally
deleted all of our social media I went
back to Lee she deleted all the tweets
all the Instagram photo started with a
blank slate and and we came up with a
new plan like we're only gonna use
Instagram for beautiful photos that will
add value to people with like these
short captions that Ryan and I write
Facebook is great for sharing links and
articles right Twitter is great for
sharing only text we don't share any
links or any photos on Twitter and by
creating these arbitrary restrictions
we've been a lot more creative using
those platforms but using those to
augment what we're already creating
they're not the main creation that makes
sense for me I just found it as a
creator it's it sort of started to drain
me especially Instagram because I was
like oh I have to make a video now oh
wait it's over a minute I've got to
rewrite it and I was just like why am I
doing this instead of making a show that
people actually care about I'm like
trying to figure out how to shoehorn my
creativity into this format and I agree
the format's are important to get the
message out but beyond that I just
didn't want to become an Instagram
influencer I wanted to just do the show
and I found surprisingly YouTube which I
usually hated is actually really fun
like what we're doing right now filming
the show and repurposing it this way and
having people see how we interact that's
been much more fun but trying to figure
out like hey quick speak faster only
we're gonna do this as a selfie and then
give a quick tip it's just it sort of
made me tired by 11 a.m. and I didn't
want to do anything else yeah if you're
trying to force it it's definitely gonna
be it's gonna be tiring I mean yeah the
other thing with social media too is it
can feel like it's productive like you
can feel like you're doing a lot of work
done
same thing with email it's like you can
spend you know six hours making the
perfect Instagram video catching up on
all your emails putting the perfect
tweet out there crafting the perfect
Facebook message but at the end of the
day it's like what did you really get
done yeah guilty of course yeah so he's
gonna do book coming out called digital
minimalism I was wondering if you guys
are gonna jump on that yeah yeah and he
he's I mean we've done a few events with
him in the past and he's like and he's
never been on social media but exactly
what Ryan's talking about here those
things eight the form of productivity so
if I ended the day like I'm exhausted I
did so many tweets and responded to so
many [ __ ] do these likes I got do
you see how many
emails list I unsubscribe from I'm so
productive and that's what it feels like
but you're not actually creating the
thing you set out to create Johnny I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life so we
talked about aligning your business with
your values well in order to do that you
need to figure out what your values are
so let me see if I got here we go here
is the book
podcast Shawn if you could reach out to
Johnny send him an audio book version of
minimalism it talks about the the five
higher order values what we call the
foundational values in our life and
setting those up too often we where we
take actions that we well our everyday
actions don't align with the person that
we want to become and so of course we
say well my Health's a priority my
relationships are a priority you know
contributing my community it's
definitely a priority but then you you
list what you've done in the last 24
hours and I'm certainly have been guilty
of this and you're like wow all the
things that I've done didn't do anything
for my values those are actually just
lip service priorities I feel like you
you see me so our book minimalism live a
meaningful life we're gonna send you a
copy of that Johnny either the audiobook
if you like our podcast you like the
audiobook or if you want the book book
or the e-book we're happy to send those
to you as well our next question is from
Tammy in st. Petersburg Florida where we
own our coffee shop
yeah I've been simplifying other aspects
of my personal life I really wanted to
be able to carry this over with in my
business practices as a portrait
photographer something that I've always
struggled with is keeping my pricing
uncomplicated while still providing
myself with an opportunity for potential
additional profits that allow me to
sustain a quality of life that I desire
it seems that almost everything you see
or read out there with regards to
marketing and sales advice these days
are all about the potential up sale so
to do this within this industry you
generally create different packages
tiers or add-ons and this is how you
make it happen but I feel that this
starts to overwhelm my clients and
honestly it
kind of overwhelms myself as well so the
easiest thing for me to do would be to
give people what they want in an easy
fashion and with probably 90% of clients
wanting digital's charging a fee for my
time artistic skills and then the
digital seems like the logical way to go
but this shoot and burn tactic as the
photography industry leveling like calls
it can make it really hard to sustain a
profit because many of my clients they
just don't understand the value of these
digital files to us as a photographer
it's basically my original piece of art
they are what I invest my most most of
my time on and once the client receives
these files they have the option for
endless usage and printing rights for
their personal use so what I would need
to charge in order to allow myself a
sustainable quality of life
I would probably cause some serious
sticker shock to most and probably lose
a lot of clients so I guess what I'm
asking is do you have any suggestions
with how to simplify this self process
for me and still allow myself to make a
profit I think ultimately if I were to
rephrase Tammy's question here is as a
business or business owner how do I
simplify my pricing in the the best way
so that I'm making an income and also
I'm adding value to the people around me
and she talked about some ways with
upsells and and add-ons we in the
corporate world back in the cellphone
days Ryan we used to call them Bolton's
like yeah in fact Ryan and I were in
charge of of measuring every single day
twice a day these 29 metrics that our
stores were performing on and so we
always had something to beat our
employees up with because they could be
doing really well in 28 and it'd be like
how dare you not sell this product
they're only 20% of your your new
accounts have text messaging on it right
it should be more like 50% 100% now well
I think there's something else going on
here with Tammy - is she is as a
photographer and especially in this
digital world it is it's very hard to
keep your own artistic creations to
yourself
so I think there's a little bit of that
going on I mean what I would say when it
comes to the the the intellectual
property if someone if I went to a
photographer so I'm looking at it from
the customer sample if I went to a
photographer and I asked them to take
some portraits of me which you have done
yes this is the minimalist
right so they take the picture of me I
paid them to to have the picture they
send me the digital's those are my
digital's that I paid the photographer
to create for me right and now if the
photographer wants to use you know my
portrait in a portfolio or or you know
just to display what she's capable of
doing great um or he but but you know
ultimately that photographer doesn't own
that the photographer can't sell my face
to McDonald's and say oh yeah I got a
great picture of a person here that
would look great for this campaign that
you're looking to do right and and and I
think maybe there's a little bit of that
going on mm I meant
am I wrong yeah I think so I think
sometimes we're very precious everything
precious to us well I mean you think
about your old business right now one of
the reasons you don't want to let it go
because I built this and it is precious
to me well and then when something
becomes too precious that to me is a
sign that I need to maybe not let go but
at least loosen my grip a little bit
that's an interesting point you know
it's very minimalist to think to think
that you should let that go that that's
a sign that you should let go where as
you're right one of the hardest things
of letting go with the old businesses
but what about all those recordings of
my voice as far as I know I kind of have
an unlimited reserve of the ability to
talk and if you ask my wife she'll
confirm that right so like what's the
big deal
those things happen in the past if
you're an NBA player and you play a game
and you're watching a replay of that
game on ESPN 17 or whatever are you like
that's mine no you're like that's a
thing that happened and now it's over
yeah yeah and and so the the word
complex the root of that word is complex
and it means to bind two things together
know that and so right now she's what
she's saying is a lot of photographers
they complex their businesses they make
it more complex by having a complex
pricing structure and if you want to the
opposite of complexes is say
or simplify and if you just want I mean
to me as a customer let's talk about
this right so so actually the people we
started our coffee shop with Joshua and
Sarah Weaver are two really talented
photographers that's how we met them
they did the photos for all of our books
and and so when we brought them out to
do some photos they were talking about
opening this coffee shop they were both
working for like these these digital
marketing agencies and they're like yeah
we're kind of burnt out on this we want
to do our own thing showcase our own
creativity in a different way and we
built a really great relationship with
them because they came out to take some
photos of us for for some books and we
quickly became friends so you'll also
learn that whatever you're doing might
lead to something else when you're when
you're building these relationships with
clients they'll lead to referrals and
everything else but we went to them and
they came to us with a price here is
your price if you want some photos you
can use them for whatever you want for
books etc and and we got to say yes or
no to that price and they felt like they
were getting what they deserve I mean
they may have felt like their their
photographer dark free is worth millions
of dollars I don't know but the market
dictated here's the price it's really
really great photographers we're gonna
come out and we're gonna do this for two
days here's what we're going to charge
you yeah I think really what what you're
laying out here Josh is that the
photographer is very aware of what the
subject is gonna do with the photos and
there's an agreement worked out between
the two of them and I mean I've got five
things right now here that I mean when
it comes specifically to the pricing
model like you can basically charge you
can do whatever pricing model you want
on a like you've if you're adding value
to your subjects and your work is
outstanding like that's really what's
important right yeah like so so it
doesn't really matter like what what
you're charging or what your pricing
model looks like I mean what's with
Sarah and Josh specifically it's like we
went to them because we wanted their
creativity because we knew of their work
and the pricing was kinda mean it's
important it's something to consider but
we weren't just shopping price right so
and it's a if you're just focused on
price it's gonna be a race to the bottom
and yes
you want those common if you're
advertising yes and if you're
advertising price it's a race to the
bottom and so I think quite often if you
simplify the pricing structure if you
remove this complexity I mean one way
that we used to do it in the corporate
world if people do want choices they
don't want unlimited choices though is
there's a reason if you walk into a IKEA
you feel really overwhelmed yeah and so
they want you know a good better best
perhaps right which is a great approach
yeah and so you you can lay out well
here are the three pricing tiers here's
what you get for that or maybe you could
just go to a client and say here's what
I charge here's the and it includes all
of this stuff I don't give you any
add-ons bolt-ons whatever here's what I
include in my service yeah and that's
that's really the second point that I
wrote down as long as your clients
understand exactly what your pricing
includes again it doesn't if you do a
good better best and and let's say that
that is totally you know not the norm in
the photography world that's okay you
can do it differently as long as the
clients the people coming to know
exactly what you're charging and what
they're getting for what you're charging
the worst thing she talked about the
bolt ons and the upsells and stuff
nothing pisses me off more I was gonna
say that yeah yeah yeah yeah no no I
mean nothing pisses me off more when I
go to to buy something and they're like
oh yeah oh you wanted oh you wanted to
take this home with you well the taking
at home charge I gotta charge you an
extra $50 exactly I mean you're never a
good customer experience you having the
convenience fee when you buy tickets
right irritating its look it I as a
business owner I've and I've photos
taken all the time if you're like hey
I'm 150 bucks and another person's like
I'm 350 let's say for some reason the
work will look similar to me I will
still go wait a minute
if the $150 photographer is like oh but
then I have to come to you and I charge
per mile so that's gonna be 47 dollars
and then oh you want to use it
commercially okay so that's an
additional hundred if I start having to
stack the math together and then the
$350 person is like oh you live 20 miles
away not a problem
yeah you want the whole day that's fine
oh okay I gotta bring an assistant that
I will pay him 50 bucks so I'll charge
you 50 bucks fine but if I start having
to go let me get the calculator out and
I'm going oh it's kind of this that I
don't want to screw with the person
who's gonna save
50 bucks but then maybe there's this
other thing I'm not expecting later I'll
just pay for the person who told me the
one price or the two prices because I
just don't care enough
you don't want clients that are gonna
split hairs over 15 bucks no or even a
hundred and fifty bucks if they're gonna
pay you two grand just charge me the
full amount I've paid photographers five
grand I've paid photographers 150 bucks
there's a difference in quality but if
we ignore that fine I still want the guy
who's gonna go yeah you're getting a
hundred photos they're all retouched the
end I don't want someone who's like each
photos 20 bucks what if I want more than
that
just simple there's something to be said
for the client understanding exactly
what they're getting and that is worth
money yeah absolutely you can
differentiate yourself not by being the
cheapest I mean that's one way to
differentiate yourself but you're going
to get the cheap clients yeah and the
the way and maybe it's fine to do that
upfront you can do free portfolio work
upfront but that's not where Tammy is at
this point you can build a portfolio and
you can you can go out of your way to do
a bunch of stuff for free to add value
to people which is going to build up
your clientele referrals etc long-term
Ryan and I'm the 99% of what we do and
99% of what you do Jordan is free yeah
and and in order to do that you we make
money elsewhere whether it's selling
books or we have patreon etc but what we
what what the way we differentiate
ourselves isn't by being cheaper we we
differentiate ourselves with being
better or simpler and I think that's
what Tammi can do here differentiate
yourself not by being cheaper
differentiate yourself by being better
and simpler than your competition
absolutely and you know women just
thinking of that $150 photographer
versus a $350 photographer so the 150
they're gonna have all these bolt ons
and upsells who are you more likely to
recommend to your friends and family
yeah hey it's 350 bucks and you get and
you get the stuff you're imagining yeah
I mean it's it to me it sounds like the
bolt ons it's just it's just not it's
not gonna generate more business what
you're doing is you're sucking them in
with a low price and then you're adding
all of these things on and that that
just doesn't create a very good customer
experience the other thing too man the
third thing I've written on is being
consistent like just the consistency is
key to so if you got a good better best
and you send me a photographer you look
for 350 bucks this is what I got and
this is what you're gonna get well then
you've got a that photographer has to be
350 for every single person I mean
people they want when someone is looking
for a service or I always say like when
I go onto a car lot like I want to be
sold like its sales is not a nasty thing
it's only nasty when we start looking at
oh how can we put a dollar on their
credit card it without them expect it
how can we do these bolt ons
and sneak those in there I mean that is
where that is where you could you know
really kill your reputation what's like
to kill your business it's like with
Derek Siver's often talks about when he
he didn't event with us in New Zealand
earlier this year and the thing that he
writes about is good marketing is
actually just being considerate yeah
that's interesting and so for being
considerate to the people that we are
selling to so good selling in a way is
being considerate keeping in mind the
needs what problem are you solving for
that person well in tammy's case it's
easy this person needs photos they need
high quality photos and they want to do
something with those photos and then you
need to be willing to go to them with
your price and charge them whatever you
feel your time and your product is worth
yeah absolutely man and the other thing
too is like Tammy she's met she
mentioned like well the sticker shock is
gonna drive clients away yeah but the
thing is is like don't I don't think
that should scare Tammy because let's
say let's say she's seven hundred
dollars she's twice as much as you know
someone else but if if the four thing
I've written out is she can prove to to
her clients why she's the photographer
they need and actually to the fifth
point that I've written down that she
understands the clients needs she can
charge whatever she wants exactly so I
Tammy don't be scared to put your own
pricing matrix out there don't don't be
spared scared to go against the the norm
of what other photographers are doing
you've just got to make sure that you
are being consistent that you are you
your clients understand why they want
you as a photographer and they want to
make sure that you understand their
needs if you're doing that I mean that's
adding a ton of value like that is how
she's gonna be successful this she's
right it's gonna drive some clients
way that's the idea you want to drive
away the person is like what I went to
Sears and I got photos for my kids for
$89 what's this all about you want $400
yeah I'm not the person at Sears this is
better here's why and you get digital's
and you get this and you get this and
you get this you're not gonna get that
from Sears and look at what you get what
you get from Sears is layers and your
kids leaning on a ladder right like this
like when you do work with me I come to
you we do this location stuff it's gonna
look a lot better and if they go now
they don't want your service they want a
commoditized version of Fatah I don't
know I can get glamour shots for half
the price
exactly yeah it's so fast Derek Siver's
again proudly exclude 99% of people so
you can focus your talents on the one
percent absolutely you're not selling
this book to people who just need
something to read right this is for
people who want to make changes in their
lives based on whatever the book is
about like the getting rid of things or
decluttering or whatever it happens to
be or clearing their thinking right it's
not a book I don't need to buy a book to
learn how to throw stuff away you
probably get that in your inbox right
well that's not what the book is about
if you want a book on how to throw stuff
away or you just want to do it for free
go ahead you're not our customer and you
have to be ok with I had someone come up
to one of our events in 2014 and they
were like you know you guys talked like
two hours up there but aren't you guys
really just saying to live intentionally
in two to live up to your values and
beliefs and I'm like yeah I guess and
they're like well why do this whole tour
and I'm like I try tweeting that and see
see what kind of response you get yeah
anything else Ryan before we move on
past Tami's question here um what are we
gonna give Tammy let's give her I'm
gonna give her two things I give her a
copy of our book everything that remains
it's sort of the five-year journey of
Ryan and I walking away from the
corporate world and walking towards
something to did a line with our values
and and you know starting the minimalist
it was this whole thing was a real
beautiful accident like I said I just
want to be a fiction writer and then I'd
simplify my life Ryan Ryan noticed like
these changes in my life and and how I
was happier even though like some pretty
traumatic events happened in my life my
I remember yeah my mom died my marriage
ended right and so I I started dealing
with those through simplifying my life
and Ryan was like oh that's cool I'm
gonna get rid all my [ __ ] too and
and then we start writing about idea so
in 2010 the hair though
actually I dabble is and grew the hair
yeah
and I have less hair now you doing yeah
very stretch all right so you know what
I'm gonna sent a me a copy of this book
because it talks about like moving away
from the perception of how things should
be and moving toward how we want things
to be but also podcast Shawn if you
could send her a copy of Derek Siver's
book it's a book called anything you
want you read that book but you haven't
read that one no it's like 80 something
pages you can read an hour I think the
audiobooks actually an hour audiobooks
flake might be 45 Derek severs and it
truly is like one of the best if not the
best book I've ever read on businesses I
like Jack yes mark I yeah and like and
he it's funny how the whole books about
CD Baby but like you can every bit of
information every little tip that he
gives you that he did with CD Baby like
you can transfer that to any other
business pretty much I feel like the
whole book is tweetable like he wrote it
in a way that is very zen but that's
that's just how Derek is so it's kind of
like that so Shawn if you could reach
out to Tammy send her a copy of
everything that remains is the audiobook
of the book book or the e-book or and uh
send her a or yes send her a copy of
anything you want by Derek Siver's and
of course if you're listening to this at
home or on the treadmill or in your car
wherever you are
we'd love to hear what you have to say
so if you have a comment or tip about
business including starting your own
business what have you learned or advice
for any of our callers today leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcasts at the
minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
and stay tuned to the end of this
episode for this week's listener
comments and tips it's my favorite part
of the show because we just steal
people's comments and tips and repurpose
them later as our own empirical wisdom
just imagining someone calling in right
now on a treadmill I was a treadmill
business you know what time it is it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media and
indeed we're on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during the
lightning round Jordan this is where
Ryan and I and now you okay
do our best to answer every question
we're just a short shareable less than
140 character response oh man but don't
worry we've Mandar on a bit and then you
can wrap it up with a tweetable bow cool
okay and so you can find all of these we
call the minimal Maxim's you can find
them in the show notes so you can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media if you like or you can find all of
our minimal Maxim's in one place now
over at minimal Maxim's com alrighty our
first lightning round question is from
Nick what's the best way to balance
hustle and rest while growing a business
should you hustle hard from the start so
you can relax in the future do when I
was reading this question I thought it
was funny so if when you're an
entrepreneur like I don't think you ever
relax now I actually know what that word
means anymore oh my god academic term
well you know what's funny man is I was
talking to Mariah about this the other
day I'm like because I've been having
such a hard time sleeping lately I got
this i got the or ring like trying to
like you know trying to track my sleep
and get better sleep and i realized like
there's always this constant pressure on
me for you know us owning our own
business now it's a pressure that that i
really enjoy having yeah but as an
entrepreneur i don't think you could
never truly just like sit back and relax
I'm always jealous of the nine-to-fivers
I know that sounds weird but I'm like
wow so you're just went home on Friday
didn't look at your email at all you
just left like yeah you just left your
work that's amazing over there oh yeah
here's the thing when we were in the
corporate world we were we weren't nine
to fivers although people think that
like five to nine errs yeah really it
was so the very first thing I did in the
morning was check my blackberry when I
woke up at 4:44 every morning hipster
and well I would wake up I'd write for
an hour and then I would start my day
and I first thing I do though is check
the BlackBerry and make sure there was
no emergencies and the last thing I did
before my head hit the pillow was check
the blackberry and I was checking it
every minute it seemed like of every day
and and you know what what do I have to
show for that well I have some I develop
some skills along the way but also I was
developing products and services for
someone else that I wasn't necessarily
benefiting directly from right I wasn't
building up these assets I was building
up some skills for sure
and so I had to think about it in a way
where I was hustling for someone else
yeah and I went a weird way was being
hustled
yeah well that's for sure true
so if I have a pity answer for this it
is this don't confuse hustle with
productivity creativity or quality and
if ii if i could have a second pithy
answer podcast jean for the show notes
here it's say yes until you have to say
no then say no until you have to say yes
oh that's so good yeah you guys are so
good so let's talk about both of those
things real quick journey so we the
first thing is well we often confuse
hustle the thing we talked about earlier
i'm GTD getting things done but are you
really good anything are you getting the
important things right most people
aren't and I'm just as guilty of this as
anyone else my to-do list do you alright
here's the sign if you have a to-do list
and you put something on it that you've
already done just so you can slide it
and cross it off I've got a problem
right you're doing the busy work and I I
still sometimes catch myself doing this
I'm like oh I did this thing I better
wait midway type in I'm like delete it
doesn't need to go in there you know
you're gamifying the system you're using
to do it or something like that you got
to be really careful with that if you
try to take these big bites what is that
book called it's like eat that frog have
you heard of this no I can't remember
who wrote this it's called eat that frog
and it's about doing the important
things in the beginning of the day
instead of like well first I need to
make sure I have no emergencies in my
inbox and then I need to make sure that
I go and by tuneups turnips whatever at
the store and then I need to feed my cat
and then I'm gonna make these calls and
then did a busy work right it's busy
work and you throw things in the way and
this is a subconscious process where you
go I really need to do the book cover
because the designers waiting for this
thing that I got to do and bottleneck in
this whole project you go but I have all
these other things to do because you
don't know what you're doing and I when
I teach networking and relationship
development to either Special Forces or
corporate people or whatever they're
always like oh it's a low priority they
don't say that but they indicate it and
the reason is because it's a black box
it's like I don't really know how to do
this but I do know how to tweet and I
know how to answer
Instagram comments and I dunno how to
craft an email for my list that doesn't
need to go out and I know how to tweet
crap on my website you push things to
the bottom that are important because
they're harder and so it takes more
cognitive ability to do it so you push
it to the end of the day and you go oh I
don't have time but look at all these
other things I did today you're depleted
you need this you can't even focus on
the important thing and then the saying
yes I mean first especially when you're
first starting a business and that
that's why I phrased it this way say yes
until you have to say no like you can
accept all these new opportunities it's
brand new eventually though you're gonna
get to a point I think Ryan and I have
done four interviews all year this year
and we've said no to hundreds of them
Shana said no to hundreds of them and
and the reason that we have said no is
because we want to focus on what we're
creating right now there will be another
time where it makes sense for us to go
out like we did in 2014 and to say yes
for hundred reasons for us to say yes we
don't have write anything but yeah yeah
exactly win doesn't make sense and so
for like Tammy when she had her question
earlier Tammy from st. Pete yes she
might have the opportunity right now to
say yes to a bunch of clients at a lower
price to build up her clientele build up
her referrals but eventually she's gonna
get so many clients her price is gonna
go up and she's gonna have to start
saying no no no no no until it makes
sense for her to say yes to the right
opportunities yeah absolutely and you
know the the dangerous thing is that the
the social media the Facebook the emails
the phone calls going and buying turnips
like this can this can feel like a
hustle and you know what actually admit
am I even you could consider it a hustle
so here worthless possible right so
here's here's my pet the answer for Nick
here an entrepreneur need and focus on
hustling as much as adding value yes
like that's people always ask like oh
man I wonder you this one you know so I
got the site hustle and I want to really
break out and you know you guys are
entrepreneurs like what what's your
biggest piece of advice and like our
biggest piece of advice is is add value
like if you are adding value to people's
lives
just like we do with 99% of our free
content people are willing to support
you with that 1% of stuff that you
charge for people aren't gonna find ways
to go out other way and support you yes
indeed all right our next question is
from Bob
how does one overcome the fear of
insecurity of moving from the safety net
of guaranteed income to the mentality
that they can succeed and survive on
one's own
well I think we kind of alluded to this
my short answer is job security is a
misnomer when your security is in
someone else's hands Amen and I think
quite often like so you're on Wall
Street you're like well this is this is
job security I've got a job that I want
now but then what happens the stock
market crashes and all of a sudden that
security you thought you had that's the
rug has been pulled out from under you
and now you're falling because you
didn't create that security it was a
sense of false security and the real
security comes when you're willing to -
well when you're willing to step back
and realize I'm gonna create my own
security first sure I agree with this
100% I think there is the the illusion
of job security in someone else's employ
and the problem that we have is
entrepreneurs or business owners were
like yeah I'm just gonna jump and then
hope what happens hope it works out
that's also a bad idea it seems heroic
now again Instagram influencers and
youtubers are like bro your job and
start a blog that's right but what I
what I would advise cuz I get this
question all the time on the yeah and
you guys are so good at naming things I
didn't name my show that Jordan
Harbinger show it just sounds so sad now
it's just my name it the minimalists com
was available for $7 that's why we're
the minitor fantastic what I always
advises hey look keep the job that you
have until and I said this earlier in
the show until you're the bottleneck
yeah and you're not the bottleneck
because someone else has to do your
social media you're the bottleneck when
you are the only thing stopping yourself
from scaling you have to be brutally
honest not just like well I really hate
my job this last month so maybe I'm the
bottleneck now no you it has to be
you're coming home from your job and
from 7:00 p.m. - whenever you fall
asleep at the keyboard you're doing
something only you can do that's when
you make the leap and you've got income
coming in and it's pretty stable from
your side hustle or whatever it is your
entrepreneurial venture don't quit
before that and that makes this choice
so much easier because people with that
what he's asking is when do I blindly
quit something that's paying the bills
and then just pray to
the powers that be that my new thing
starts making money you don't the answer
is you don't do that don't do that
absolutely so you know I guess going
from the art of charm to what you're
doing now right like you like you would
mention at the beginning of the podcast
like there's you're making good money
that you know there's there's this
stable source of income is there any
practical and I got some practical stuff
too but I'm just curious Jordan is there
any practical stuff that that you did to
ensure like you know what I can walk
away from this paycheck and I can start
something else and and and feel you know
you're always gonna have a little bit of
fear but to alleviate as much fear as
possible I guess what I did at first and
this was kind of an accidental discovery
what I did at first it was like step one
panic step two
and but limit your panic to like a
couple of days depending on how
traumatizing it is my friend Hal Elrod
who you guys might know he's like you
you can feel sorry for yourself for 15
minutes and this is a guy who had cancer
I think twice and almost died in a car
accident so I'm he can speak credibly on
this particular point no one ever to
leave this guy yeah he's amazing I'll
introduce you guys well and he wrote
this book called the miracle morning
it's it's pretty interesting what I did
was step one panic step two make a list
of people that I know will help me and
this list could be a hundred people but
what I did is I started with like 10 or
12 who I knew would not say no and the
reason I did that is because when you're
feeling low down out defeated whatever
it is you don't want to call people
where you're like hey can you help me
and they're like oh I'm really busy
because you'll start to feel even worse
because you'll see your support network
slowly slipping away call 10 people that
day or the next day and you go look I'm
having a really big problem can you can
you help me that first dozen people that
you call that help you you start to feel
bulletproof you're like well if I've got
12 really good friends behind me I'll be
fine
and this can be your parents but it's
even better if it's not right because
then you're like okay it's not just my
family who's like you can do it honey
thanks mom you can do it in your hands
yeah and your mama's handsome boy
that'll only go so far but if you call
your friends and they're like yeah I'm
happy to figure out how to help you
that's when you start to go wait a
minute I have a huge support network and
so what I encourage people to do I call
exercise layoff lifelines cuz it's like
imagine you get laid off who are the ten
or so people you wish you'd kept in
touch with like your college guidance
counselor friends right like because if
you make that list now and it's like oh
you know I should have kept in touch
with Josh and Ryan and I should have
kept in touch with my high school
guidance counselor and I should have
kept in touch with that old boss and I
should have kept in touch with these
professors that were really good make
that list now reach out now because then
you don't have an agenda because the
problem is people go oh it's so awkward
to reach out it's awkward to reach out
when you're like hey man haven't talked
to you in eight years so I need a job
right so I need help now Sunfire can you
come put it out for me write it that is
awkward we're working on our second
documentary right now and on the
soundtrack that we're working with Drew
and Nate on from this band we there's a
song called asking on there and the line
is it just man it hit me like it though
and you can't listen to it yet so
there's nothing I can give that's
impossible but but the line is I'm sorry
I didn't call I've just been busy yeah
and like but it when you hear it in a
song especially if that's the thing it's
it's not like you're setting these
people up is I'm gonna need to use you
someday we're set it up and say hey man
I screwed up I didn't keep in touch with
this relationship let me find a way to
repair this this is something that meant
something to me it doesn't mean they're
gonna be your best friend forever now it
just means that your your repairing or
your reconnecting with this person so
you can have a meaningful relationship
with them if they need something you
need to be willing to help them out this
is what a relationship is is there's an
us box in every relationship I'm I'm
giving what I can give and I'm taking
what I need you know everything I can
take but taking what I need from the
relationship yeah Jordan III I think I
just want to highlight how like when
you're going and asking for help it's
not even like you're looking for
handouts man yeah it's like when when
you're asking for help you're looking
for support but I think the other thing
too is like you all you are also
offering support and I think that is how
you can really make these relationships
strong and you do have people to kind of
fall back on I mean it's you know maybe
maybe Bob here doesn't have you know
someone who couldn't offer him a job but
you know maybe maybe Bob has some folks
who could
tell their friends and family about you
know what he's doing or whatever but but
yeah it's it's it's so important to hold
on to those good relationships my pet
the answer would be this it's kind of
kind of rewrote Josh's that even
realized I do that
it is betting on an employer rather than
yourself
guarantees disappointment yeah even
though you're being employed I really
love what Jordan saying here it's very
practical it's not like well just quit
your job and do what your follow your
passion yourself out there and so like I
think what's true is yeah okay maybe you
don't have job security but if you're
betting yourself even in the job you're
gonna have better job security in that
job you control the mechanisms that are
you're able to to control there yeah
every promotion that I got in the
corporate world and I got quite a few
O's by age 27 I was the youngest
director in our company's 140 year
history which sounds really impressive
until you you realized that like well I
was the the sort of middle manager of
who gives a crap you know a director
position the week before you're the
director now yeah and the young rats
happened to be the oldest one to know
and what I realized in in that scenario
is I never applied for any of the
promotions I got I worked hard and
adding as much value as I could so that
I was the clear person to to pick for
the next thing and you can do that now
you can pick yourself even if you're
working within a corporate structure
you're working for a small business or
you're working for yourself it's
important to pick yourself yeah it
absolutely is I mean you know Bob you
might get fired tomorrow your employer
does not look out for you they look out
for the company and to sit there and say
oh well I've got this guaranteed source
of income you do not have a guaranteed
source of income you have something
consistent that you've gotten maybe over
the past months years whatever but
there's nothing guaranteed in life
especially your job
I think practical you know some
practical advice save up six months
worth of bills like for me
that is what really gave me the courage
to when I got laid off well the way I
got laid off is it was a month a month
before I got laid off I asked to speak
to my boss and I'm like hey
and you know about the minimalists and
he know that I'm probably not gonna be
at this company for the rest of my life
I want to talk to you about what we're
going to do who were gonna replace me
with if I happen to leave and he was
like oh that's a good question he's like
man he's like you've got things running
pretty well he's like this thing is it's
going pretty well he's like I don't I
don't even know if I would need to
replace you and I'm like I'd sign yeah
well for me it was it was I just looked
at him like huh that's an interesting
thought is that and then the next month
I get a phone call hey man I need you to
meet me you know in room 207 across from
HR were like we've laid off dozens of
people before like I knew what was
coming but having that conversation with
him and I knew I was planting the seed
in his head and having that conversation
with him I don't think I would have had
that if I hadn't saved up six months
worth the bills it's not like you know I
was looking at this safety net like oh
man I can do anything I want because I
got six months worth of bills but what
it did do is it gave me confidence to
give myself some time a little bit of a
buffer a buffer to to go out there and
find another source of income so I mean
just practically Bob save up six months
worth the bills that will alleviate a
lot of fear oh yeah good point and it's
hard to do that because people go oh six
months of bills no problem
then you start looking at what you're
getting you're buying and you're like
wait a minute I probably don't even need
to do that you look at the budget and
say I'm actually Price pen and way too
much right now I just spent less and I
focus on what is truly essential what is
non-essential than what's junk in my
life I can pare down my current bills
and by the way that's six months that
number is going to be a lot smaller
right and I'm not trying to make this
sound simple I mean it might take
someone six years to save up six months
worth of bills but but that goal of
having that throughout your work career
like that is I mean for me like I just
can't even express how much leverage
that gave me when I when I wanted to
talk to my boss about that PS gentlemen
we have one more question here from Paul
Paul asks what are the first steps to
start a business we have we have a
lawyer here with us today so when should
I hire an accountant and attorney
employees and other professionals to
help me manage my business and if you'd
like to hear our answer to that question
you can listen to this week's
script episode over at the minimalist
private podcast that's right every week
we record an additional podcast episode
and it's available exclusively to our
patreon supporters so if you want to
support our show and keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our ask
the minimalist anything episodes
unreleased recordings of our live events
we just put out our Perth event recently
so you can check that out as well as I
think we've done about 15 within the
last year Wow a lot of events only for
our patreon supporters and you can also
check out the entire back catalog of
past private episodes once you become a
subscriber you'll also receive a
personal link to our private podcast
feed so that it plays in your normal
podcast player you can find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional podcast episode every week
over at the minimalists comm slash
support and here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode
[Music]
look unless you're doing some sort of
service where you could have a problem
right don't worry about the legal
structure just yet their sole proprietor
is a thing that kind of just happens and
the problem is you don't have a
corporate veil to protect you which is
fine unless you're like a barber and
someone slips on your floor then you
want insurance you want to make sure you
have a corporate structure but if you're
just working from home solving some
thing for people you don't really have
to worry about that get an accountant at
the end of the year to help you save on
taxes and things like that but you don't
need to have an attorney an accountant
and have all this corporate structure
stuff set up and then spend 10 grand and
then be like cool now I can start doing
business right start making money first
all right now it's time for our
added-value portion of the show Jordan
this is where each of us talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently it can be a book or it
can be an experience it could be a
physical good because quite often when
people think of minimalism they think of
those stark white walls owning nothing
experiencing nothing just being a monk
in a cave but the truth is I get far
more value from the few things that I
own and the experiences that I that I
have way more value than I used to when
everything was precious to me I had to
hold on to everything I just figured you
guys lived in like the Apple Store
without any of the phones or iPads and
that's what your houses look like it's a
great idea who's the architect John
Paulson who like I mean if you google
search him he's like he has the most
beautiful aesthetic sort of apartments
but like architecture and but it's so
stark that like yeah it's not functional
who live in Magneto's prison from x-men
you know so I'm five-year-old daughter
and the thing is about five-year-olds
that when we move into new place were
waiting we waited months to get a couch
and she did not notice at all that we
didn't have a couch we didn't have a
dining-room table I just didn't care at
all and I think that's sort of as we get
older we assume we're supposed to have
these certain things and I personally
get value from having a couch and having
a dining-room table
but you realize that like man maybe I
just I've been sold a bill of goods I'm
supposed to have these certain things in
order to to make me happy but the truth
is there are some things that add value
to our lives I'm gonna recommend two
things
that have added value to my life
recently I've got two books here since
we're talking about business I'm only
six chapters into this but as Seth Godin
Zanu book this is marketing I'm sure
you've seen it he's been marketing the
hell out of it but this is marketing but
I'm only six chapters through but I
thought this was this was apropos
considering we're talking about business
today but we talked about Derek Siver's
and marketing how marketing is being
considerate in Chapter six he talks
about beyond commodities and you talked
about how we were just selling
commodities we're commodifying stuff I
knew but he knows
no yeah not us well I mean we if we not
intentional about it we can too and yeah
and so we always have to step back and
saying is this adding value or am I just
trying to squeeze a dollar out of this
thing so he talks about effective
marketers don't begin with a solution
with the thing that makes them more
clever than everyone else instead we
begin with a group we seek to serve a
problem that we seek to solve and a
change that we seek to make and so
that's I think ultimately if you were to
sum up what we're talking about today is
we're trying to help people solve
problems and that's that's what
effective businesses do that's what a
minimalist business would do but then
the other book I want to recommend today
is it comes out in January it's called a
company of 1 by Paul Jarvis do you know
Paul I do yeah he listens to my show and
he wrote to me and I was like oh I love
when smart people who wrote books write
in there like I listen to you because
it's so validating yes Paul thinks he
always knew it he's super talented but
this book in particular I wrote a blurb
for it and the blurb was effectively
like your business can thrive with less
he talks about responsible growth or the
idea of not needing to grow your
business maybe your business is big
enough or maybe you even have to shrink
a business in order to grow it
effectively going back to Johnny's
question and so we'll put a link to this
in the show notes as well it's called
company of one but it's a mindset it's
not just about being an entrepreneur but
if you are entrepreneur I think it's a
great book for you but even if you're
working for a corporation he talks about
the company of one mentality of working
for yourself but also doing so with
fewer resources I think this book will
help you out a lot I've got the advance
copy here but it'll come out in in
January and you all can pre-order it now
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes Ryan what's adding value to your
life recently
you know how my sleep sucks mentioned
that earlier in the podcast Moriah
bought this it's for sig manic reishi
mushroom elixir and it's basically it
aids deep sleep so I will say man like
if so the not last night the night
before I didn't drink any and I got zero
deep sleep last night I drink I got like
25 minutes of deep sleep but what I've
noted and that's not the first time I've
I've had that where I forgot to drink it
and didn't get any deep sleep back to it
really really does like I mean it
according to my aura ring like it
definitely makes a difference with my
deep sleep now twenty five minutes a
deep sleep still sucks really bad better
than zero minutes yeah exactly so I
would recommend like if yeah if you're
looking for another sleep aid like it's
it's a pretty natural healthy thing to
take Jordan what's been adding value to
your life recently it's funny you're
talking about sleep aids I actually got
an air purifier it was from a sponsor
and I thought like okay fine whatever
it's like a the iPhone of air purifiers
I get this thing and I put it in and put
it to work and I'm like let me check the
filter see what's in here
oh my gosh there's disgusting stuff in
the air inside your house oh you have no
idea and I thought like is this a trick
is this filter slowly degrading so that
it looks like all this crap is in the
air and granted I live in NorCal so
there's wildfires but I don't leave my
windows open it's closed and I have two
cats that don't have any hair I've
hairless cats so there's not like cat
hair and pet dander in there there's
just gross
crap in the air and I noticed that my
sleep I track my sleep with aura and
with the Apple watch and things like
that and my sleep quality has gone up
I've been able to fall asleep better
it's just incredible the other thing and
I don't know we're probably supposed to
give one but this is such an important
thing for sleep there's this I mask that
I got and it's like almost like a little
pillow that straps onto your eyes and
it's very soft and it has a little
cutout for the nose it's not one of
those elastic band ones it literally is
like a pillow quilted thing that goes
all the way across your head this thing
knocks me the heck out and I'll wake up
and go what time is it and my wife's
like 7:30 and I'm like wait you mean to
tell me that I slept through the entire
night I didn't get up 58 times starting
at 4:00 a.m. to like go to the bathroom
and then that flawlessly I just jumped
out and I'll look at my watch and it's
like wow you slept like a boss last
night you know the brand of the eye mask
whiskers like I'm interested now yeah
I'll find it okay I'm so sorry that I
don't this thing is it was like 30 bucks
and people like 30 bucks for an eye mask
you're an idiot you can get one on an
airplane for free this is different it
doesn't let in any light like a
Bluegreen yeah I think it's a well we
yeah
yes yeah it's that one might be this
yeah it is sort of satin or sometimes
yeah it's that one it's so good yeah
we'll put a link to in the show so Shawn
you already have the link to it I don't
know the brand name but I know that it
works really well I don't even have a
brand name might just be like sleep mass
it's amazing I was wearing it last night
so I could attest to it as well all
right let's move on the right here right
now where we talk about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalist before we
do that I just want to say thank you to
Jordan um if you're if you're listening
to this check out the Jordan Harbinger
show where can they find you on social
media you're at Jordan Harbinger right
I'm at Jordan Harbinger on all forms of
social media thank God nobody took that
I looked and I looked there's no other
Jordan harbors that I can find anywhere
in the world wow you're lucky man you
know man I guess so yeah but Jordan I
think you're super talented
interviewer and I'm really grateful you
decide to spend this I think this was
really informative it's fun and
christmas is coming up when this will
this will be out one week before
Christmas and so have you considered
buying gin a brick for Christmas a brick
yes like an actual brick for a house yes
well for more like a grocery store so
Ryan and I are from a town yeah so we're
from a town called Dayton Ohio right
I've heard it yeah just right down i-75
from where you grew up that's right and
I see you from Michigan right yeah I am
yeah so so we grew up in Dayton Ohio
spent the first 31 years of our lives
there and the second largest food desert
in the country is on the west side of
Dayton a 40% of the city lives in West
Dayton and there is not a single grocery
store on the entire west side of this
how is that possible I know right that's
good the last one closed during the the
Great Recession
so 2008-2009 the Kroger they're closed
and there is not a single grocery store
store there so people don't have access
to healthy food and so what Ryan and I
are doing this holiday season we are
trying to get people to buy bricks on
behalf of their friends and families
it's the gift of contribution a brick
with labor costs about a dollar Ryan and
I are trying to raise the last hundred
thousand dollars to build a grocery
co-op we've we've partnered with a
company called Jim City Market and it is
a is a food co-op it's gonna be the only
grocery store in West Dayton and I think
we're over 60% of the way there but we
need our audience's help so if you if
you need to do some last-minute shopping
for
ribs bricks
you just go to the minimalists comm /
brick you can see the video that Ryan
and I did you can also donate you can
buy a brick for each of your friend and
family members so spend 20 bucks buy 20
bricks for this co-op and you're doing
something really good you're helping
provide food for people who don't have
access to healthy food them and they can
go to a liquor store and buy some
Cheetos or simple are doing right yeah I
used to work in downtown Detroit and I
was like where do people shop and he
goes at the corner store I'm like that
place sells booze cigarettes there's
like milk that's five times the price of
milk could be any let's do people don't
have cars they have to walk there yeah
and I was like how are you getting out
of poverty when you're paying five times
more than I'm paying at a Whole Foods
for them food that's exactly so what
we're trying to change that in Dayton
Dayton is very similar to Detroit in
that respect and and we're trying to
we're trying to provide an option for
people so if you're interested you want
to help out and also by the way people
who get this you you can you can print
it out you can put an envelope as a
Christmas gift it's a stocking stuffer
everyone will be grateful for that and
it's an opportunity that anyone can
contribute to I've had so many people
say hey all I had was a dollar to be
able to donate to this so thank you for
making it available for anyone who wants
to contribute something so if you want
to contribute a dollar great if you want
to contribute a thousand dollars great
we're really grateful and it's doing
something meaningful so head on over to
the minimalists comm slash brick and
while you're over at the minimalists
comm we also have well we have 29 ideas
for a debt-free holiday so jordan i
don't know if you know this but
twenty-eight percent of people are still
in debt from last year's Christmas
Christmas gift Oh twenty eight percent
of people and then of course we're gonna
go further into debt by buying more
useless stuff with money we don't have
we're buying things we people don't want
and giving it to them because we feel
obligated to do so so Ryan and I we when
we talk to our friends about what are
some of the cheap or inexpensive or free
experiences or consumables that you can
give for the holiday season so once
you've bought all the bricks that you
can buy and you want to still contribute
to other people what are the experiences
there's 29 different ideas over at the
minimalists comm slash idea ideas
and if you want to comment on this
episode you can do so over at
youtube.com slash the minimalists also
on YouTube we're doing quickie episodes
of the minimalist podcast we're doing
living room conversations where Ryan and
I answer questions in our living rooms
or in our homes and we're doing a house
tour soon as well every Sunday at the
minimalists calm we will send you an
email with some sort of writing essay
video etc if you want to sign up for
simple Sundays it's just the minimalists
com enter your email address up there
we'll never send you any spam we'll
never send you any junk or any promo
waste stuff but you will get any new
writings that we put out you also get
the podcast show notes in your inbox if
you're interested in checking out the
show notes just head on over to the
minimalists comm enter your email
address at the top Ryan what else you
got for us
Jordan so we live in a meme culture
right now man like we see a meme when we
take it for fact or we see a headline
and we're like oh my god like that's and
then we start telling all our friends
about this crazy headline and lately
Josh and I we basically been encouraging
our readers to re our listeners or
viewers yeah and our readers to really
read more to to get a diverse opinion
and when they see a headline when they
see a meme to really look into it to see
whether or not something is is in fact
true so I'm just gonna leave us with
with encouraging people to read more and
to stay informed oh you know what I got
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hey Josh
and Ryan this is Sarah from Dahlonega
Georgia I was just calling about your
city's episode a few weeks back and I
just wanted to say that if life takes
you to a city that you think you're
going to hate you may find out that you
absolutely love it personally I was in a
long-distance relationship for three
years and the only way my wife and I
could figure out how to be together was
for me to move to the small town of
Dahlonega in Northeast Georgia and I am
originally from Houston Texas and I
thought I would absolutely hate living
in a small
two hours away from a big city that I
would miss all of my amenities and to be
honest I was kind of miserable for the
first three months until I started to
allow myself to enjoy the beauty of a
small town and living in the foothills
of the Appalachian Mountains and being
able to enjoy enjoy new amenities and
things that I never thought that I would
enjoy I never want to live in a city
again I've lost 40 pounds I'm the
happiest I've ever been in my life and I
just wanted to say that if for some
reason you find yourself somewhere you
don't think you'll like look for things
you might like because it might just
change your idea of what the perfect
living situation is for you hey guys
this is Chris from Raleigh Durham North
Carolina I'm calling in regards to the
upgrades podcast podcast 162 I didn't
hear it on the podcast itself but I am
or I was rather forever in the state of
trying to upgrade my job until recently
and like to address that a little bit I
just wanted to say that there are ways
that you can either find a way to be
okay with your job not feel prey to
ambition our fall prey to ambition but
rather to be okay with where you're at
maybe find a way to upgrade your salary
without upgrading your job or find a way
to upgrade your money situation by
taking a side job or looking into things
that you like to do that could bring in
some side income and perhaps that side
income can grow and scale into something
that's a little bit more lucrative and
before long you're doing the things that
you like to do full-time and making a
living at it
hi guys it's Ali from Australia calling
just a recommendation for Christmas
gift-giving that I've borrowed from
Roberto Lavoie from the fantastic
podcast mom and dad are fighting
she calls it treasures from the Attic
and it's a Kris Kringle type of setup
where each family member selects another
family member but rather than purchasing
a gift you need to consider something
that you already own that you feel that
the other person would like as a gift
and then you choose a household item to
wrap that gift you're not allowed to buy
wrapping paper so you could use
newspaper or tin foil or something
around the house we do this with our
five sorry a three kids last year and we
gave them full responsibility for
selecting their gift and wrapping it
they were aged eleven eight and five and
they've really loved it and asked to do
it again this year last year we received
things like books and jewelry someone
received some tools note paper it was
really nice this year I'll be getting my
six-year-old son the experience of using
my claw foot bath something that I
usually determine as completely
off-limits to my children so yeah it's a
I thought it was a great idea and it's
been with the most memorable and
enjoyable gift-giving experience in our
family all right Joe that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists or a comment give us a call
for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can also email
a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message oh well two things
actually Jordan thank you so much once
again for having me on in your grateful
and if you all leave here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus